mesdames messieurs bonsoir mirapolis
c'est parti jacques chirac a donné le
coup d'envoi cet après-midi en igor en
inaugurant officiellement ce premier
parc de loisirs de la région parisienne
aux côtés du premier ministre messieurs
méhaignerie et de villiers façon de
rappeler que mirapolis par le biais de
rabelais et de garde dans tu as touche
au patrimoine culturel
manière de dire aussi que mirapolis est
un enjeu dans le développement
économique du val d'oise de la région et
de la france
ce qu'a d'ailleurs souligné jacques
chirac insistant sur le plus touristique
qu'entraînerait ce parc de loisirs